joining us on the line is Senator Ted
Cruz of Texas senator Cruz how are you
doing sir
man I'm doing terrific how are you doing
I'm doing pretty well man the news cycle
is hot and heavy these days obviously my
mind has been on the chaos that just
broke in Israel where Prime Minister
Netanyahu is about to be indicted it's
complete mess
over there yeah I have I have a feeling
that that yeah literally anything could
happen over there what was your sort of
take on that breaking news
well it's certainly on unfortunate news
and and I think Prime Minister Netanyahu
has been an extraordinary leader for
Israel and an extraordinarily strong
friend of America and and I think in
particular the role that Netanyahu
played when when Obama was president of
speaking out with with a Clarion
strength against the disaster that was
the Obama Iran nuclear deal I've
referred multiple times to the
forcefulness
of Netanyahu's message to the world as
really being Churchillian with that
force and and gravitas and so it is
obviously dismayed to see the the legal
challenges there and obviously the
difficulty of forming government they've
now had two elections and not been able
to form a government it's ultimately up
to the people of Israel to decide who
their head of state should be but but I
certainly hope this gets resolved and
and and we go forward because Israel is
too poor important of an ally for them
not to have a strong and effective prime
minister to lead Israel and stand along
with America what an absolute mess well
speaking of absolute messes I don't know
senator Cruz if you hadn't the
opportunity to watch the democratic
debate last night but that was a that
was a clown car I mean it was it was
pretty wild too to watch as a bunch of
candidates who theoretically should be
you know going after each other in
search of the nomination decided instead
that they were going to just group hug
this whole thing out while proposing
some of the most radical proposals
imaginable what was your take on the on
the outcome of last night's debate so
I'll confess I didn't watch last night i
watch the first few and they're they're
sort of a limit to my masochism I
at this point it is evident where the
Democratic field is going which it which
is that they are galloping to the left
there's no spot too far left for them to
go and and and the animating force in
the Democratic Party is rage it is raged
towards Donald Trump they hate Donald
Trump that is what unites them as a
party and as a result they're embracing
it and more extreme positions that but
even a few years ago were fringe
positions on in the Democratic Party you
look at the leaders among the Democrats
you look at Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders that these are our fringe
leftist candidates you know Bernie is an
open and avowed socialist it used to be
Democrats pretended they weren't
socialists now just about every one of
them openly embraces the socialist
agenda just about every one of them
openly embraces the green New Deal which
would be 90 trillion dollars in new
government spending more spending than
the federal government is spent in the
history of our country just about every
one of them in braces open borders just
about every one of them embraces
unlimited abortion on demand up to the
moment of birth and even after birth
with taxpayer funding and just about
every one of them and embraces full-on
socialized medicine making it illegal
for you or me or any of us to have the
health insurance we have right now I
mean these are radical extreme positions
and yet you see these Democrats lining
up and raising their hands like like
lemmings wanting all of America to jump
off a cliff I mean senator Cruz I will
admit that I found it very amusing to
listen to the Democrats last night you
missed it but it was it was pretty funny
to watch them list off their credentials
for being presidents of the United
States said from Joe Biden
who actually has served you know in
Congress for years served in the Senate
for years was vice president actually
has his name on some legislation it
Bernie Sanders saying that he was worthy
of the job because he's been a career
useless person you had Buddha judge
explained that he is worthy of being
President of the United States after
winning his biggest election with a
grand total of eleven thousand votes in
South Bend Indiana because he's the
least wealthy person on stage that was
literally his pitches that he is not
wealthy therefore he should
the world's largest economy you had you
had a camel Harris explained that she is
part of the intersectional coalition in
these are not folks who have a strong
leg to stand on when it comes to a
record of achievement it seems to me
yeah I think that is right and they also
don't have a vision that makes sense for
America look the number one priority
from Texans my job is to represent
twenty eight million Texans that's what
I go to the Senate to do each and every
day what Texans care about is jobs we
want more jobs we want higher wages we
want more opportunity what Texans care
about is security we want our our home
safe we want our border secure we want
the nation kept safe what Texans care
about is freedom we want our
constitutional rights protected we want
free speech and religious liberty in the
Second Amendment all the fundamental
liberties that we enjoy as Americans
protected that that is a common-sense
agenda that has wide bipartisan support
among the voters and yet the the clown
car that is that the Democratic 2020
primary field is talking about none of
that and in fact they're opposed to
every bit of that you know you've got
Elizabeth Warren proposing not just
repealing the tax cuts but imposing
massive new tax increases that would be
crippling to the economy and and and
that you you know I I never thought I'd
say it but but but I look long fully
back towards the days of a Bill Clinton
where there was some plet something
resembling a Democrat who was willing to
say gosh jobs are good none of these
people believe this the only jobs they
want is more government tax collectors
to kick down the doors and take your
guns that's that's the only jobs they
have they're not gonna have any Border
Patrol agents they're not going to
deport anyone they're gonna have open
borders so apparently the only jobs on
earth are IRS agents and welfare agents
given out cash half the people are
taking our money the other half are
giving it away the people aren't working
that's their agenda and I gotta say Ben
that's nuts it's pretty astonishing well
meanwhile you've been co-sponsoring the
Hong Kong human rights and democracy act
obviously things are getting quite ugly
over there with the Chinese government
violating the rights of the people of
Hong Kong
British it seems to me never should have
given up sovereignty over Hong Kong to a
communist Chinese government that had no
intention of moderating the failure of
the West to understand that the Chinese
government was never going to moderate
just because their income went up
through free trade it never fails to
astonish so what is the situation over
in Hong Kong and what is this bill
designed to do well I'll say what's
happening in Hong Kong right now is both
deeply dismaying and incredibly
inspirational at the same time what is
dismaying is we're seeing a brutal
crackdown from the Chinese Communist
government where they are trying to use
brute force to suppress freedom and
democracy in Hong Kong
now what's inspirational is we're seeing
millions of men and women in Hong Kong
leading protests going to the street I
was in Hong Kong just last month I went
there I met with the protest leaders I
met with democracy activists you know
many of them are young people our
students are young men and young women
who are going out and I mean risking
their lives we're seeing Chinese
Communist police officers violently
assaulting the protesters of violently
engaging shooting one in the stomach and
unarmed protesters shooting and shooting
with a firearm in the stomach firing
rubber bullets at other protesters we're
seeing brutality and and I think the
eyes of the world are on Hong Kong I've
said many times now Hong Kong is the New
Berlin and just a couple of weeks ago we
celebrated the 30th anniversary of the
fall of the Berlin Wall and just as
Ronald Reagan stood before the
Brandenburg Gate and said the most
important words any leader is said in
modern times mr. Gorbachev tear down
this wall likewise those protestors on
the streets of Hong Kong who are waving
American flags who are singing the
American anthem who are holding up signs
with quotes from our founding fathers
they are fighting for liberty they are
fighting for democracy and the Chinese
Communist government is terrified they
are terrified that 1.3 billion Chinese
men and women will see that and want
freedom too and so I was very glad this
week to go to the Senate floor to join
with other senators Democrats and
Republicans in passing
legislation that has America standing
with Hong Kong standing with the
protesters and standing up to the
Chinese communist oppression let's let's
talk for just one second about the
impeachment inquiry so the polls are
actually swinging it appears against the
Democrats on the impeachment inquiry
Democrats continue to trot this thing
forward presumably hoping that it will
actually hurt Trump in the election
because they know this is going nowhere
in the Senate what's your take on this
on this you know back pattern overall
well I I think that's right I think
what's what's happening in the house has
become an absolute circus and and House
Democrats have given up on any pretense
of fairness or objectivity you know if
you look at previous impeachment
proceedings in the House of
Representatives if you look at the
proceedings with Richard Nixon if you
look at the proceedings with Bill
Clinton in both instances the house made
a real effort to be fair to be objective
to allow both sides to present their
case they allowed the minority to
subpoena witnesses so that you had a
full and complete record in this
instance House Democrats departed from
past practice and they said the minority
can call no witnesses we're not going to
allow the minority to have subpoena
power and instead what they're engaged
in that this is a show trial it is a a
propaganda trial where the House
Democrats will only listen to testimony
they believe supports their narrative
and they don't allow the defense to
present any facts on the other side and
and and and I think the American people
see this this is not a fair and
objective process designed by the house
to find out facts to find out evidence
it has a preordained conclusion which is
House Democrats decided in November of
2016 they want to do impeach Donald
Trump because they're mad at the
American people for electing him and all
of this is a show trial towards a
preordained conclusion now the good news
is when the house votes to impeach and I
believe House Democrats will largely on
party line vote when it comes to the
Senate I hope and believe the Senate
will do much better that we will have a
fair proceeding we will have a
proceeding that respects due process
that allows both sides to present their
case that allows both sides to be able
to call witnesses and address evidence
and
and I think the show trial House
Democrats are doing our only undermining
their case because it makes it very
clear it is a partisan proceeding rather
than a proceeding governed by rule of
law now senator Cruz one final question
for you on this if it reaches the Senate
which it likely will I can't imagine a
situation which House Democrats don't
vote for impeachment and this reaches
the Senate trial should the Senate call
some of the witnesses that the Democrats
will not call including folks like
hunter Biden including perhaps people
who will talk openly about the identity
of the whistleblower who got this whole
case started in the first place how
broad should the impeachment inquiry
beam once in the trial once it gets to
the Senate well I think that's very
likely I think the the proceeding in the
Senate should be fair it should be open
and it should respect due process what
does that mean that means allowing both
sides to present their case and if the
White House chooses to call as a witness
hunter Biden if the White House chooses
to call as a witness the whistleblower I
think they should be allowed to call
them that I think both of those
witnesses in particular may well be
integral to the White House's defense
and the position of the House of
Representatives is there an ostrich
sticking their head in the sand they're
like no no no we won't hear any
arguments for the defense you know it's
a little bit like Alice in Wonderland
verdict first trial later that's where
the House of Representatives is their
verdict is impeachment and they don't
want to have a trial and so yes if the
president defense team wants to call
hunter Biden or wants to call the
whistle blower or any other fact
witnesses that are critical to their
defense of course they should be allowed
to call them because that's what due
process mandates is that is that you be
able is that both sides to be able to
present their case and it be decided on
actual facts and not just a political
hit job now senator Cruz really
appreciate your time thanks so much for
your work out there appreciate it bad
thanks for all you do